cruz à bonjour aussi sterling alors
mettez moi de vous présenter flash
mcqueen c'est vous l'après 13 la
motivation vous me dites que mcqueen et
là monsieur sterling mais c'est très
bizarre je ne vois pas il est devant
vous vous ne les voyez pas non et il va
enfin il est juste devant vous c'est lui
flash mcqueen c'est un imposteur c'est
évident il a les ruses et en bout de
course
regardez moi c'est plus classe que vous
exagérez un corps réagissent et bah oui
bon d'accord je dois transformer la
colère en énergie la motivation c'est ce
qui fait la différence monsieur mcqueen
toutes les émotions négatives peuvent
servir de carburant pour positiver je
n'ai jamais eu de mal à positiver je
suis quelqu'un d'assez autistes et moi
je suis trop contente de vous entraîner
quand j'étais petit je vous regarder à
la télé quand vous étiez peut-être tous
ces jeunes sont formidables mais je
préfère les vrais défis je ne suis pas
sûr d'ailleurs entre nous je vous
appelle mon projet senior
ma vie c'est qui c'est
jackson storm oui c'est un des rookie un
merci merci à tous c'est sympa confie
beaucoup merci et jackson storm c'est ça
bravo magnifique course
ouah merci monsieur mcqueen vous
n'imaginez pas à quel point je suis
content de pouvoir enfin vous éliminez à
merci quoi ta excusez moi j'ai pas bien
compris m'éliminer vous avez
parfaitement compris
oui oui oui allez-y faites une photo
vraiment fair-play
vous vous rendez compte que ce champion
a été mon idole pendant des années j'ai
même envie de dire de très nombreuses
années un vieux j'adore ce qu'ils sont
trois est touché un point sensible
[Musique]
alors c'est bon la vitesse je ne sais
pas du tout il faudrait que vous rouliez
sur le tapis nord pas de tapis aux
demandes ont hamilton ici hamilton s'est
dit hamilton hamilton et mon assistant
électronique comme ce qu'il ya sur les
téléphones vous avez un téléphone
maintenant pas du tout gros je suis une
voiture de course hamilton annoncé les
vitesses de monsieur mcqueen
je suis prêt j'essaierai de rester dans
votre sillage votre coque électronique
transmettra votre vitesse à hamilton
d'accord si vous voulez vous allez
devenir la plus grande icône commercial
des circuits film publicité parrainage
de produits catia
vous pensiez être déjà célèbres ou pas à
nous sont fabuleusement riche qu'est ce
que vous essayez de me dire monsieur
vous ne courrez pas cette saison
chaque fois que vous perdez vous fait du
tort
je suis navré votre carrière arrive à
son terme
on ne peut espérer qu'une chose c'est
que cette course ne soit pas ça dernier
c'est moi qui déciderai quand
j'arrêterai
comment tu te sens je peux pas retourner
sur les circuits recommencer comme avant
ça marchera plus on peut pas aller
contre le progrès tu sais ce que je
ferais moi j'ai pas gagné mais je suis
trop content de vous entraîner
j'adore les défis d'ailleurs je vous ai
baptisé mon projet seniors romain
la plage marc vallée sharon stone a
établi un nouveau record aujourd'hui en
enregistrant le meilleur temps jamais
réalisé courant du nord que ce sens
vient de battre tout envisagé ne prend
pas soin
c'est ma dernière chance cruz la
dernière si je suis battu
aucun sponsor ne voudra engager
n'ayez pas peur de l'échec ne portait
pas battu d'avancé vous avez votre
chance
quand je regardais à la télé on aurait
dit que vous
que vous n'aviez pas peur de rien
j'aurais voulu connaître cette sensation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il sera jamais aussi rapide que ce temps
tu vas être plus malin que lui
pennec la course comme récompense le
reste je m'en fiche la probabilité d'une
victoire le storm est de 94 2%
[Musique]
makoun
tu n'es plus le champion tu as été
acceptée j'arrêterai quand je l'aurai
décidé
jackson storne fait partie de la
nouvelle génération de coureurs high
tech
troisième report pour l'étoile mandat
tu ne seras jamais aussi rapide mais tu
peux être plus mal vous avez besoin de
mes services monsieur mcqueen
je vais m'occuper toi storm
diable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
coefficient de traînée -2%
débordante + 5 %
vitesse de pointe plus 1,2 pour cent
tu sais ce qui t'attend
plus de puissance plus de vitesse
plus de rim
donc perdu 8 ans et plus
tu ne seras plus le coureur que tu as
été
on ne peut pas remonter le temps flash
mais on peut remettre les pendules à
l'heure
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où